With a little planning.
Positioning buttonholes
for your knits isn't hard.
The Knit It Now Button Hole Placement Tool
will walk you through all the decisions
you need to make step-by-step and generate
knitting instructions so you can knit
bands with perfectly spaced buttonholes.
Start by entering the gauge of the stitch
pattern you'll use for your band.
Next, add the details of your buttons.
How many holes?
How long is the band?
What size button hole do you need?
How much space do you want from the top
and the bottom edges of the band?
Armed with your answers,
the Tool will generate your knitting
instructions and you won't
have to do any math.